you said that you're not going to defend
your title anymore so how do you feel
about it now after one year and what
impact has it had on your own life and
on your chest in motivation it feels
pretty similar as to what it did last
year and also for that that I'd sort of
mentally checked out of the world
championship and
it feels good not to have to to worry
about it in terms of my motivation I
think now for a number of years the
motivation has come and gone a little
bit and you can see that in some of the
tournaments that I I play sometimes you
can sense that it's really really
important to me is other other times
tomorrow like ah we'll see how it goes
and then the results often often show
that so I I think like you know recently
I haven't played so well but I've had
bad stretches before and I'm definitely
motivated now to strive back in this one